Assassin's Creed Valhalla footage leaks
come lavigne the dude behind Bioshock
he's got a new game and it's got some
weird in it and that Xbox event is
actually officially happening this month
I'm Curtin Davina this is safe State
GameSpot's sweet fun new show for Monday
July 6 welcome this weekend Ubisoft was
gonna have movie soft for a live events
showing off some of its new games one of
them being Assassin's Creed Valhalla
however 30 minutes gameplay footage has
leaked online now before we go any
further let me make it clear that we're
not gonna show that footage because some
of you may not want to see it so know
that you're good but we'll talk about
what's in it the footage is the first
real look at the female version of a ver
apparently showing her riding a horse
riding a longboat fighting some wolves
and breaking into a castle now
supposedly the gameplay footage is quite
grainy and has some aspects that clearly
aren't finished yet and I say the word
supposedly because I actually haven't
seen it nor do I plan to but it's
assumable we're gonna be seeing a lot of
that game and finished like state this
Sunday July 12th 12 p.m. Pt during the
Ubisoft Ford event where we'll likely
see watchdogs Legion and also the new
battle game hyper scape which we have a
ton of stuff on including an hour 1/2
gameplay footage of it on our channel
inside so look in the description below
for all that stuff alright so take 2 is
currently in the process of reviving the
Bioshock franchise without its designer
creator and writer Ken Levine
however ken Levine is working on
something within take 2 that has quote
some weird in it speaking at the game
lab 2020 event ken Levine talked about
his wider outlook on game design
providing minor teases about whatever is
next saying quote if you don't have
people saying that sounds a little
insane you haven't gone close enough to
the edge and quote and well Ken Levine
is certainly known for it is insane we
don't know anything about it or when
we'll be seeing something about this
game but we know that it's being
developed by ghost story games where
he's the president of huff in the
meantime we do know that cloud chamber a
new studio is working on the next
Bioshock game it was reported last week
but now we have an official date the
Xbox 2020 live event is going to be
happening on July 23rd Thursday at 9
a.m. Pt it'll be heavily focused on
first party games like Halo Infinite and
there's speculation we might be seeing a
new fable and perfect dark but we'll
have to see still there are a lot more
Xbox 2020 streams to come as we still
have many unanswered questions like how
much is this thing gonna be when is it
coming out and are we gonna be getting
one of the cheaper Lockhart models lots
of answer questions we'll find out
eventually in good time I'm remaining
patience I really don't have another
choice
Skype chill I guess Lilly did you hear
GameSpot is doing play for all a
multi-week charity streaming event we're
from every single day from 12 p.m. to 2
p.m. Pt we're featuring special guests
and raising money for charity like black
lives matter and people fighting on the
front line for Kovan 19 relief look at
her she can't even handle it she's just
melting at the very idea of such an
amazing thing happening but yes that's
right we're doing it we're still doing
it and it's still happening everyday so
coming up tomorrow Tuesday July 7th we
have a charity stream with the top 5
Skyrim mods of all time with sub and cam
and then we also have movie trivia with
Jack Pattillo and then on Wednesday July
8th we have another charity stream with
Elise and James of Willems also we're
always adding new special guests so you
can check out the full schedule in the
description below now accompanying this
is a bunch of exclusive content
interviews with developers doing cool
stuff that we're we're all excited about
so yeah look out for that too
ok that's it for today of course you can
find out about everything I just talked
about in a whole lot more by going to
gamespot.com again
I'm Karina Vina thanks for joining me
thanks for being here
thanks for being a part of GameSpot's
sweet funtime news show safe state ok be
well
you know what's up see you later